pas
toi y'a plus d'intervilles parce qu'elle
fut si tron oui hein mais c'est tout à
fait vrai on va lui demander de te poser
une question à l'est on écoute bien à ça
me fait plaisir mais ont ils si léon
zitrone 16 114 2013 pour vous en dirais
mon chéri est ce que vous me recevait je
ne l'entends pas ah on me fait signe que
nous sommes de l'antenne ma question guy
vos contrat actuel avec les scènes
françaises belges et surtout suisse
court jusqu à 2037 vers quelle activité
allez vous vous consacrez en exclusivité
je vous donne le choix camelot éleveur
de vaches cette barrière sur lévriers ou
directeurs de casting à silicon valley
choisissez